to make an impression darling hi my name
is Eric singer and I'm back Eric is
still spending his days being a dialect
coach for film and television
let's talk about some more video Lex
what's an idio lect an idiot
is one individual person's way of
speaking so let's look at some more
actors playing real people
rami malek Freddie Mercury we're for
misfits who don't belong together
playing to the other misfits the
outcasts right at the back of the room
we're pretty sure they don't belong
either we belong to them well this is
amazing as performance deserves every
plaudit that it got thank you let's talk
about a couple specific speech things
first of all I don't think I've ever
talked in one of these videos about
prosthetics but of course prosthetics
are incredibly common especially when
actors are playing real people got to
make an impression darling you look like
an angry lizard can change the look and
shape of the face with prosthetics and
of course that's going to affect the way
the actor speaks well duh Columbo in
this case it's hard to imagine playing
Freddie Mercury without those teeth yes
of course of course it takes time to get
used to something like having
prosthetics in your mouth something
interesting about the way he does adapt
to this there's that very immobilize a
mallet I'm going to be what I was born
to be a performer let's talk about one
more little detail which is Freddie
Mercury's s sound an S sound is a
sibilant sound Mercury's s is a hyper
sibilant sound which means it's higher
pitched it would want to be entertained
in various ways various ways the way you
get that is by moving the tip of the
tongue if that's the part of the tongue
you're using to make the S sound closer
to the teeth the lights the lights and
what's interesting here is that those
teeth are further forward than they
might be in somebody else mercury you
sort of say I'm a big star star star
Moloch and we'll punch a hole in the sky
sky Wow
Claire Foy queen elizabeth ii 25 years
ago 25 years ago my grandfather
broadcast the first
grandfather broadcast the first of these
Christmas messages so Claire Foy's
accent here is clearly a kind of antique
RP RP has received pronunciation it's
that accent we associate with the
British upper classes and upper middle
classes queen elizabeth ii has a very
heightened RP accent here's Her Majesty
the Queen
I very much hope but this new medium
will make my Christmas message more
personal and direct
I think if Claire Foy had gone for that
accent precisely it might have been too
much
here's Claire Foy is version I very much
hip but this new medium will make my
Christmas message more personal and
direct so she's catching the spirit of
it she's doing a lot of the vowel sounds
most of the way but not all the way I
think that's a great choice here I took
a lot about oral posture which is the
shape and feel of an accent it's kind of
the logic that holds the individual
sounds together because the individual
sounds arise out of that oral posture
the oral posture for this accent is very
high the jaw is high the tongue tends to
be a little bit tenser in the mouth and
so we get some sounds that are a little
bit higher a little bit tenser in terms
of the tongue position in the mouth you
can hear that in the pronunciation of
the trap vowel in the word happy happy
Christmas here's the Queen pronouncing a
similar vowel sound with that raised
position happy Christmas
happy Christmas another example of this
connection between this oral posture and
sounds is in the goat vowel you can hear
it here in the word remote and here's
Her Majesty the Queen rather remote
figure - many are killed well rather
remote figure to many of you Joseph
gordon-levitt Edward Snowden well
they'll charge me under the Espionage
Act and they'll say i endangered
national security and
demonize me and my friends and family
and they'll throw me in jail
it's so cool he's doing so much so
Edward Snowden has a really particular
an interesting vocal quality some of
which comes from actually pushing down
on his lyrics he's physically lowering
it I have a really prominent Adam's
apple you can probably see it so here's
the real Edward Snowden my name is
Edward Snowden and here's Joseph
gordon-levitt
my name is Edward Joseph Snowden there's
a very characteristic thing that
Stoughton does with what we call a high
fall it's got a shape like that in terms
of the pitch contour you can hear it
here on the word passport passport
here's Joseph gordon-levitt America was
founded on passport founded on Passport
trapped me trapped me Computers
Computers and here's Joseph
gordon-levitt
on in the world everyone in the world in
the world and really wrong really wrong
really wrong even when it's not exactly
the same amplitude is still the same
shape computers really will trap me
security O'Shea Jackson jr. Ice Cube me
all the way in a house I just paid for
up the strength of what you told me I
mean you gave me your word I want to
talk about a particular feature of
English called th fronting th sounds or
most of the time made on the teeth tip
of the tongue either behind the upper
front teeth or in between when those
sounds are realized as more of an effort
V sound so with the lip and the teeth so
this pose or mouth roofless we call that
th fronting because it's a little
further forward so IceCube demonstrates
th fronting here and the word ruthless
and the ruthless posse
the wolf the wolf and in this rap he
demonstrates the same thing in ruthless
and in toothless here's O'Shea Jackson
jr. ice cubes real son doing the same
thing in this rap on one of those two
words but not on the other one
so Ice Cube is his actual dad apparently
he had a lot of input into the
performance in all kinds of ways so I
think that's cool are we finished here
gary oldman Winston Churchill we shall
fight on the landing grounds we shall
fight in the fields and in the streets
this is an extraordinary performance
Churchill's s sound was kind of the
opposite in a sense from Freddie
Mercury's s sound it's not hyper
sibilant it's hypo sibilant so it's
lower pitched and the way that happens
mechanically is that the part of the
tongue that's making that S sound is a
little bit further away from the teeth
instead of being closer to it further
away you get the lower the pitches
exertion you could try that yourself
move the part of your tongue makes your
s tongue tip up tongue tip down closer
to your teeth and then further away you
can hear the pitch raise and lower as
you do that so church also is pretty far
away which gives it a lower pitched s
than Freddie Mercury's higher pitched
one so here's Rami Malik's hyper
sibilant s punch a hole in the sky sky
and here's Oldman's hypo sibilant one
[Music]
there's yet another detail of the way
he's making this single sound which is
that Oldman is doing it with his tongue
tip down so that the groove for the
Airstream is in that part of the tongue
right behind the tip and Churchill did
exactly the same thing and we can hear
that listen to Churchill's boats and
comrades there you bow-like good
coverage seas and oceans which will
fight on the Seas and oceans
and here's Oakland on the seas and
oceans cognates come Ridge Jennifer
Lawrence joy Mangano
it's lightweight it's the only mom that
you ever gonna buy the best not be ever
gonna use it is lightweight and durable
and that is just me speaking from it my
experience so I think this is a great
example of that middle road more subtle
route and playing a real person without
going for some kind of uncanny oh my god
that's the person's voice hi I'm joy
Mangano and I invented the miracle mic
the only mom that you ever go by is
literally the last mop you'll ever have
to buy so this is a really recognizable
Long Island accent it's marked by a
bunch of things one of those things is
nasality
and the way you do that or what I mean
by that there's an opening at the very
back of your vocal tract called the V
low pharyngeal port it's the opening
between the vellum which is the back of
the roof of the mouth and the pharynx
which is the back wall of the throat you
can open that so air can escape through
the nose and that's what we get is
nasality if you go and you can close it
and no air gets out through the nose
which is what you have to do when you
make a sound like but otherwise there
would be no buildup of that air pressure
and if it's closed we don't have a lot
of noise ality and the boys what she's
done is she's opened it a bit less so
than the real joys well you know it's
300 feet of continuous loop cotton
continuous cotton loops continuous loop
runs definitely more than her own
natural voice I never care I was with my
two kids with my father care father care
thank you thank you there's an
intersection here between that nasality
and particular sounds like the sound in
the word hand it gets a little bit
tenser I would get glass shards and my
hands hands the way she says the word
durable here is just pure Long Island so
it's lightweight but very durable
durable
Kameron written at Kemper I knew a week
before she died I was gonna kill her I
knew a week before she died I was gonna
kill her she said for seven years for
seven years she said I haven't had sex
with a man I haven't had sex with a man
because of you my murderous son my
murderous son okay so I think this one
is really interesting he
not doing absolutely everything he's
doing some things very specifically and
yet the effect is uncanny there's so
much that just feels like he's caught
the guy's soul she says why suppose
you're gonna want to wait on us sort of
all night and talk now so a couple of
really specific things at Kemper's top
lip barely moves and it's really only
the middle thirds of the lips on the top
and bottom that are active they hardly
ever come into full rounding
here's Brittain I wasn't impotent but
emotionally I was here's Kemper
I wasn't impotent but emotionally I was
impotent it's doing some really
interesting stuff with the pacing too so
different from the real Cameron Britton
who we can see here once we were done
shooting I expected the character to
leave but you didn't want to and here's
this very slow deliberate pace with
these very carefully chosen words she
had a very violently outspoken position
on men and here's Kemper again and had
had very strong and violently outspoken
position on men okay John David
Washington Ron Stallworth look here some
people say we've got a lot of malice
some say it's a lot of nerve and want to
talk about something kind of basic but
here's a term the term is rotisserie we
can talk about accents as being Rohtak
or non-rhotic can you give me any
examples
Rotech means we pronounce the R after
vowel sounds where it's like car here
fear non-rhotic accent would not
pronounce those ours yeah the car
something like that
and Ron stallworth is a very
consistently and obviously Rohtak
speaker
we always hear those ours after vowel
sound I launched a investigation into
the Ku Klux Klan a chapter that was for
me chapter a chapter so Washington is
doing that for sure
the Escalade talk calmly firmly he's
also doing something else interesting
though which is when he's on the phone
with the Ku Klux Klan he's bumping up
the rotisserie national director - huh
director - no sir and what I mean by
that is something very specific and
physical this weird articulation that is
American are involves the sides of the
tongue coming up and touching the upper
molars and the bicuspids on the sides
and sometimes pressing out against them
bracing muscularly against the insides
of those teeth ron Stallworth here and
that's what we kind of hear is like a
harder are pure Walter now the real Ron
stallworth has said that he didn't
actually do that he did not change his
voice on the phone he used his own
accent that's what I said oh hell what I
do though JD Washington does make that
little adjustment and I think it's
fascinating all right yeah absolutely
sure he doesn't do it in an obvious way
I think that would have had a different
effect I kind of love the way this works
though in helping to tell the story of
this film I can tell you're pure Aryan
white man from the way you pronounce
certain words John Cusack Richard Nixon
but do you really want that spoiled rich
son of a to be your next president
that isn't for me to say could be
disastrous that's exactly what's gonna
so I think there's a few ways of
approaching this you know one of them of
course is we can all think of
performances where somebody has gone for
a really uncanny almost eerie Eve
occasion of a real person we see at the
other end of the spectrum I think
sometimes both people will play a real
person and decide kind of not to do
anything to go for that person that can
be an entirely artistically valid choice
I think it all depends on what the story
is and how you're serving the story it's
kind of an in-between approach to I
think which is to kind of pick a few
features and serve your lightly evoking
the character and I think that's what
Cusack is doing here I did I think he's
very far away in his own natural voice
from Nixon's voice and vocal qualities
well I like doing a voice overs because
they're so easy is that in the National
Security Council so your people
hopefully have been in the cabinet find
the easy thing to do as an actor it
looks like a tasty truth sometimes it is
not yes it's easy so I think that's
probably a wise choice in this case he's
pinning most of this I think on rhythm
and that kind of grumbly drawn-out last
syllable and I think it's effective for
the story Thank You Susan all right
let's look at another Nixon now this is
about the Watergate nonsense well I'm
not a crook I've earned
everything I've got I had nothing to do
with it okay so I think there's kind of
a standard model Nixon we've seen a lot
of Nixon's things like this CIA has no
policy except what I dictate to you for
this one if you really want to get
inside Nixon's head you have to use a
processor one of the things that I think
a lot of these include is this very
characteristic
oral posture which has to do often with
the sort of the lengthening of the tube
that is the vocal tract in part by
tensing the cheeks in and sort of
squishing lips forwards with a lot of
relaxation in the middle thirds of the
upper and lower lips I have never
profits they're the liars here you know
I welcome this kind of examination it
won't protect them from me the other
thing he does though that's a little bit
subtler is there's a little bit of what
we call a pharyngeal squeeze which is a
kind of tension or squeezing narrowing
in the throat back sort of behind the
various parts of the tongue and mouth
and he does that especially on our
sounds after vowels you can hear it here
in 24 for instance at the age of 24 24
so here's Nixon doing it in the words
require and quitter will require a
quitter at the age of 24 that's a really
neat and fine detail I think they cost
me and one more Nixon here's Frank
Langella you got to do a lot of things
sometimes that are not always in the
strictest sense of the law legal so I
think there's another way to play a real
person that I didn't mention which is to
sort of slightly heighten everything
right there we usually see this in
comedy impressions this is not obviously
this is a really serious performance and
I think a brilliant one but it is
interesting to notice the way he's kind
of taken each feature each of these
characteristic things and just
heightened it slightly sort of turned
the dial up to 11 when the President
does it that means it's not illegal when
the president does it that means that it
is not illegal let's just look at
Langella slip corners here and compare
them to the real Nixon's I had nothing
to no knowledge of the fact that it was
going to be paid
all of these features are there but in
the real Nixon may be slightly more
subdued and I have to carry that burden
with me
for the rest of my life the rest I let
the American people down I love the
American people though my political life
is over my political life is over
Felicity Jones Ruth Bader Ginsburg a
hundred years ago Myra Bradwell wanted
to be a lawyer she had fulfilled the
requirements for the Illinois Bar but
she wasn't allowed to practice because
she was a woman there's so much that is
wonderful in this performance I am gonna
be picky here and just pick one thing
out Ruth Bader Ginsburg's native
Brooklyn accent is consistently
non-rhotic use the word gender to become
a father with a partner and Felicity
Jones does a great job of that right
here Myra Bradwell wanted to be a lawyer
lawyer but moments later she has a very
Rohtak pronunciation of the word bar
filled the requirements for the Illinois
Bar we wouldn't expect to find that in a
non-rhotic speaker I'm asking you to set
a new precedent Claire Danes temple
grandin I could see the world a new way
I could see details that other people
were blind to everyone worked hard make
sure that I was engaged I think this is
wonderful two fascinating performance
there's so many details see detail
physically I am movement and certainly
certainly speech was a neurological
disorder today Einstein would be
diagnosed with some kind of autism blood
speaking too I was for no speech until
age three just a zero in on one thing
which is she's changed the direction the
orientation of her tongue tip when she
makes tea d NS and some L sounds Claire
Danes normally makes these sounds with
her tongue tip towards her alveolar
Ridge that gum Ridge behind the teeth
thank you so much Mateen Mateen whereas
Temple Grandin used the blade of her
tongue which is the bit of the tongue
right behind the tip so the tongue tip
is oriented down and it's the blade of
her tongue that's making contact or
getting close to that alveolar Ridge you
can hear that here to entertain a kid
one time for five five teen teen time
Claire Danes has adopted that completely
kind of a hard thing to change that
takes a while
two two five five two five two amazing
details Adrien Brody Salvador Dali
I thank you sad eyes and big lips
melting or the hot descend the one tear
so that's ridiculous right I mean
completely over-the-top here's the real
guy look I see you do it in the ordinary
way so he is - he was immensely
theatrical very good yes what do you do
with that do you tone it down because
it's gonna seem like too much you think
it's pens yes in Midnight in Paris Owen
Wilson travels back in time and meets
all his heroes and they're all
larger-than-life so I think this fits in
with that Salvador Dali in real life was
kind of larger-than-life all no bueno
fiddles no sir
so of course he is in the film and it
serves the story very good very good
so we talked before about Winston
Churchill's tapped our there's another
kind of our that makes contact with that
gum Ridge and that's a trilled
R so in this case it's gonna make
contact a few times Spanish has both
kinds of are the tapped R is spelled
with a single R and the trilled are
conveniently is spelled with a double R
so you can make a distinction between a
word like pero and Pedro Dali does a
trilled are here they Mendel's play
Mendel and Adrian Brody in very
theatrical seeming fashion because it's
really theatrical to trill an R in
English but Dali did it
here's Brody suspended and Christian
Bale Dick Cheney I think you cannot be
blown off-course I think you cannot be
blown off-course
so Bale has actually said he wasn't
going for an impression of Cheney I
guess an uncanny a vocation of the guy
focusing on what's the essence you know
not wanting to do just an impersonation
but there's so many fine and accurately
observed details here physical things
that sort of tilt of the head
the way they had alternately sort of non
side-to-side and comes forward in a nod
for emphasis things like his vocal
quality as well and of course that lip
that's raised up on one side into a kind
of a sneer here's something really fine
look at the way the lips spread quite
wide together with that head nod for
emphasis here in bales performance on
the word that you got a deal with that
and on the same vowel sound and Cheney
in the word ass and asked them if we
thought when they asked in the gasps
Michelle Yeoh on son Suchi have you
heard anything yet quickly before they
cut the line I think what could sort out
a lot of problems any sign at all that
they were let you go and very much in
favor of negotiations ok so there's
something here that is really a
high-wire act Michelle Yeoh delivered on
sons hoochies speeches in Burmese a
language who doesn't speak that's kind
of amazing I'm not sure her Burmese is
perfect some Burmese speakers have said
it's a little weird nevertheless an
incredibly impressive thing to have
attempted thank you her accent in
English is a little bit inconsistent and
I think this is one of these cases where
the actor really would have needed an
enormous amount of support and a lot of
time I'd say six months to prepare for
something like this when you include
those Burmese speeches here we have her
sounding mostly like Michelle Yeoh
quickly before the cut line it's really
from 88 until 90 we will continue
in a colony fashion where's here we have
her really nailing on Sansa she's very
hyper educated Oxbridge English accent
any sign of old soul they all have a
stake all told all all have a stake in
the future of this country I've never
actually spoken in public before anyway
if she didn't have the proper support
and time which I really doubt she did
did this all on her own it's still a
really impressive job thank you
Carmen ejogo Coretta Scott King what do
you intend to say to these people dancer
a lot of work has been done here and I
don't intend to see it undone tonight
let's go down a rabbit hole Coretta
Scott King has two very different
pronunciations of the word her really
close to each other in this interview
let's listen to them I also said to her
you are so brave I didn't see her so
they're inconsistent that's the person
she's a real person and she's got two
different pronunciations very different
said to her Ciara said to her Sierra
listen to karma Nijo goes to different
pronunciations of the final syllable in
the word Minister and in the word sir
when is Rohtak with an R and one is
non-rhotic just a vowel sound
what do you intend to say to these
people dancer you've said disrespectful
things in the past minister that's
inconsistent but it's inconsistent in a
way that people actually are in their
own accents that's important and
interesting to note that real people
have that kind of inconsistency
conclusion speech is about the most
physically complex thing we do as human
beings so what do we need for that time
and really good support really good
coach actors don't always get that so I
think these are things we always need to
keep in mind with these performances but
wow this is fascinating fascinating
stuff I think we can all agree
[Applause]
[Music]